breaking overnight a powerful Pacific
storm battered the Pacific Northwest
with high winds as many as 100,000
people lost power for a time on Friday
in Seattle the wind sent a tree crashing
down onto a house some streets and roads
were blocked by fallen trees more severe
weather is expected in the West and in
the east meteorologist ed Curran of our
favorite Chicago station wbbm-tv has the
latest
ed good morning we like that well we'll
start with the rain that's off to the
East Coast here we're watching this
large system that's tracking to the east
and that's circulating here in bringing
range to southern Illinois and all the
way out to the southeast and up to
Washington DC as well we're particularly
concerned about flooding that's possible
because of the persistent rain and
because of melting snow in this area is
why we have flood watches and flash
flood watches that are up for today
here's the way the system will track as
we go into the afternoon today into
tonight and into tomorrow bringing a mix
of precipitation rain and snow appear to
the north and finally into New England
now let's take one look out to the
northwest this is where we have high
winds high surf warnings gale warnings
even a winter storm watches more rain
and snow with windy conditions come
roaring in to the Pacific Northwest
Anthony some tough stuff out there
thanks ad